hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to layers of fear now
I'm just gonna explore here this may
just be a continuation in the last
episode but this may be a brand new
episode so we're gonna find out I really
hope it's I really hope there isn't any
more well someone lied to me someone
lied to me I'm not emotionally ready if
there's more oh joy
hickory dickory dock dick a mouse ran up
the clock the clock struck one or ran
down hickory dickory dock someone's
getting a little maniacal I don't know
why but maybe you could calm down a
little bit and take care of your
daughter that might be a smart decision
there I might be good might be a little
bit of good know but seems like there's
more seems like there's a whole lot more
hello
what the f or what huh what was that
belly bazaar oh hey you're looking out
for me bro you got my back these are
dangerous times around here in this
house I need a friend I need anyone I
need anyone at all I didn't expect to be
doing another episode who did that
did you see who it was Oh what is it
what are you doing Oh dark
Oh for [ __ ] sake could someone shut up
that damn dog scratching it squeaking
behind the walls is bad enough I found
that at the beginning of the game why is
it here stop getting smaller you're
supposed to be looking out for me bro
he's like yeah I got you I'm just gonna
back away slowly don't worry about me a
guy I still got has to got you I got you
hey hey is there something behind me oh
god it's you who's he who all along see
I always got your back bro oh then I
that's an eye isn't it yeah it's an eye
oh god damn uh why why oh hi
back up
whoa whoa whoa whoa Nelly well calm down
oh okay good
come by finally awoken from this
horrible nightmare another drunken
stupor stumbling around my own house
being murdered by my own wife fun times
my voice is starting to go by the way my
voice is starting to go hello okay this
looks dark and fun this looks dark and
awesome this looks dark amazing
who wants some what's what's on that
painting
[ __ ] okay
oh just gonna I'm gonna close the door
I'm gonna back up I'm never gonna go in
there again yeah that's what I thought
it was that's what I thought alien mold
lady
no dunno don't know okay I guess we're
done now
I guess it's done and now we're gonna be
okay cool
can't wait yeah this is fun
oh there oh hello hi oh okay
we're just playing the game of cat and
mouse for some damn reason why stop it
I'm gonna leave now I'm gonna leave oh
good can can someone end this torment
please
why wagon
okay did I die
was that me dying how did I die
what happened did the rats kill me was I
not supposed to go towards the rats I
mean I have a funny feeling that I'm
supposed to you know die oh hey watch it
with that thing you have to be better
than this throwing things at me
my level of spoop okay
thank you okay I'm dad again that time I
don't think I was supposed to die I'm
pretty sure that was just me being
stupid and running into the death
because a curtain scared me after I was
about to say that my levels of spook
tolerance were high oh it's different
oh it's different okay
this weird are you thinking dearest wife
I know that the past few months have
been devastating I know that I should
have been more supportive more caring
more selfless I still can't believe some
of the things I said to you I guess I
was never meant to be a great husband or
father I thought I could be a great
artist but that dream has ended as well
in its absence I will do my best to
treat you with all the love and
compassion you deserve you are the love
of my life my muse you will never read
this letter I am so sorry did he write
that after she died oh this is so sad oh
man
I don't know what's going on here as
bizarre my voice is just about gone from
all the involuntary screaming oh geez oh
god damn it okay what do you got oh so
I heard some yeah that's that's what I
thought I heard I just I was hoping I
was wrong what do I do a little pain
goes a long way tell me about it but
what do I do
oh this okay I know
No Oh No
I can't push it the other way what did I
do
oh god it's why is it dark okay good
wandering into the darkness would not
have been my first choice oh I hate this
oh I hate this oh I hate it I hate it
okay hi okay hi hello let's see let's
consider our options knife quick
personal painful too messy why not have
the strength to pull it off painkiller
overdose gun rat poison poison paint
poetic which poison where would I get it
from
so he's contemplating methods of suicide
that's awesome way is there something
over
nope just a bunch of whispers from the
Damned
okay Oh another ride oh I can't wait
it'll be so much fun
hope not that way here we go it was door
oh hang on here we go OOP
okay there we go
this game this game is wearing me down
this game is this game is eating away at
me this game is getting to me oh that's
fun
great great oh no oh no no is it some
there oh there is oh no oh no oh no oh
no no no no I'm just a helpless little
baby
don't please Oh No
again I am dead for whatever reason tie
him dead I don't know if there was a way
to avoid that one definitely not Oh
what's this body borrowers feeding on me
driving me insane too fast to cut out
that's that's a was that body burrowers
your body borrowers prime borrowers not
again not again with the phantom baby I
gotta be so flippin weird well you gotta
be so flippin weird why can't it just be
normal
why can't it just be normal Oh what's
that what is that oh oh this is the
scene from before that was the baby
scribbling but something went horribly
wrong with that baby's head something
went horribly wrong with this baby's
everything hi oh oh it's so warm and
inviting oh yeah
hello hi
is that what they call chromatic
aberration you wanna you want to have
you want to hug it out okay everyone she
wants alone time okey-dokey then
okay never mind it's quiet now Oh back
here again oh good I was hoping I was
hoping hello what hello
just get one second I got let me just oh
oh oh oh the Artic this this art anomaly
draws tens of thousands of mediocrity
enthusiasts and sundae abstraction
aficionados result of a week-long art
marathon not very well adjusted painter
locked into dark basement leaving aside
the horrible execution the painting
excels in hideous Oh
okay good good good good
there's my booze is my pipes alright I'm
coming for you
hello baby-faced you okay
what are you looking at now wait a
minute what are you looking at looking
at it's three six three huh okay good
clue good clue three six three okay find
that did that what oh that's a little
weird
oh hi what am I not supposed to be
concerned about all of this hellhole
that's above me is it just that nothing
all right you know you know what it's
okay I hear a phone frankly I don't
think it matters okay bye-bye bye-bye
now goodbye Oh knows it Oh that was it
Oh so good Oh finally it's over so there
were only four items but there was
another episode's worth of scares to be
experienced man my throat is just
thrashed if it sounded wow that's weird
if it sounded like you know I was like I
was I was having trouble speaking
because my throat is just thrashed from
the amount of like totally involuntary
screams that I've I've experiences in
this game man this is this good oh it's
so good it's like it's so well made in
that it crafts them well like it crafts
the world I mean a lot of it is what
would be called jump scares but still
it's very environmental and it's very
stuff I gotta stop talking because I got
to get my voice break but thank you
everybody so much for watching thank you
so much if you want to see more scary
games that I've done check the links in
the description below or the annotation
is over there thanks again and as always
I'll see
come on